I'm about
Continuing in Al Wajeez
The guitar of Tahara, book of
purification.
And the sub-chapter regarding the
various types of najasa, the various
types of filth.
Yesterday morning we mentioned the first
two, which is urine and feces, human
urine and feces. Human urine and feces.
Number three and four
are al-madhi
wal-wadi.
Al-madhi
is a
discharge
that is noted as being clear
and it comes
out as a result of sexual desire or
stimulation.
Al-wadi
is something that is usually noted as
being white,
cloudy,
and it comes out of the bladder after
urinating.
These are two things that come from the
bladder
or two things that come from the
from the front
private part. And so,
al-wadi
is clear
and it emerges
during arousal.
Right?
Number two is al-wadi
with a D, D.
D as in dog, wadi.
And this
comes out of the bladder after
urinating. It's not common, it's not
normal, it shouldn't come out of the
bladder,
but usually if there's some kind of
infection or you know, someone when they
get older in age or something that,
al-wadi will start to discharge after
the person has finished urinating and
all of the urine has come out, after
a while this wadi will come out. Both of
these
are
considered to be najis. They are type
of najasa. Right? They are type of
najasa.
[Silence]
So, an-Nawawi rahimahullah
shares here that al-madhi,
which is
something that is a clear discharge that
comes
when the person becomes aroused,
during arousal.
This is
something that is not particular to
men or women. Both men and women have
this.
[Silence]
So, the evidence that al-madhi
is
considered a type of najasa
is the narration of Ali ibn Abi Talib,
which is in Bukhari and Muslim.
That
he said, "I was someone who had this
problem." Meaning in his younger years,
he had this issue with al-madhi. The
slightest arousal would cause this madhi
to discharge and I would be very
shy
or or I was very bashful to ask the
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
regarding the ruling on al-madhi. Now,
we take a stop there. We look at Sunan
Abi Dawud. Ali ibn Abi Talib mentioned
that he really had a hard time with this
because
he
viewed this, I mean, he didn't have the
knowledge of the ruling of this. It
comes out only as a result of sexual
desire. It comes out when one is aroused
and it is very closely akin to semen
which comes out at at climax and so he
would bathe every time this would
happen. A bath for najasa for
janabah.
Radiyallahu anhu.
Ijtihad, right? From himself. And he was
too bashful to ask the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam cuz he was
married to
Fatimah radiyallahu anha.
So,
in Sunan Abi Dawud he says that he
fought with this for a long time to the
point that in the winter his back was
cracking and bleeding from the amount of
times he would bathe in the cold, right?
Bathing to
make salah.
And so, he sent al-Miqdad ibn al-Aswad,
one of his friends, he sent al-Miqdad
ibn al-Aswad to ask the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam on his behalf
about the ruling of this.
On his behalf, meaning like
"Doctor, this is not for me, this is for
a friend, right?" On his behalf, not to
say Ali sent me, but you know, to make
it seem it was his own question.
And so, the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam says, "Yaghsilu dhakarahu wa
yatawadda."
He said he should wash his private parts
and make wudu.
So, this was a huge relief for Ali
radiyallahu anhu. And where do we
understand from this
sentence?
He should wash his private parts and
make wudu. From this sentence, where do
we get that the conclusion, how do we
conclude that it is a type of najasa?
[Arabic recitation]
us
the
extent of what ignorance does to a
person.
Imagine if he continued to be this.
Imagine if there was
he he had no access to knowledge. He had
no access to the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam. He had no access to a
person of knowledge.
How many years would he have done this
for?
Bathing every time this happens. Huh? A
lifetime? Could he Could most people
last a lifetime under that kind of
pressure?
Huh?
Not even with our modern showers and our
modern access, most people won't last a
lifetime. And a shaytan uses that,
right? Says, "Look at this. What kind of
religion is this?
What? So, every time this happens you
got to take a shower. Go shower. You
can't do anything because you're busy
showering, right? This is a curse. This
is a this. This is a that." Until what
happens?
Human being is going to break
eventually.
Right? How precious is knowledge? And
not only that, but when a person meets
Allah having gone through all of this
struggle,
this struggle was unnecessary.
If they had access to knowledge or a
person of knowledge and continued to
suffer and failed to ask,
there's no reward for this. Nobody asked
you to do this.
Imagine that. Imagine the calamity of
just that alone in a person's life. And
now times that times 100, 200 issues
that a person will have in his life.
This is why we need knowledge. This is
why knowledge is more important than the
air that we breathe and the food that we
eat.
[Silence]
So he mentions three now. Abdullah ibn
Abbas
in Sunan al-Bayhaqi, he mentions three
things. They all sound the same and they
all come from
the they are all come from the private
part
from the front
outside of the urine.
Okay?
So he says al-mani
wal- madhi
wal- wadi.
Memorize them, right? Al-mani
wal- madhi
wal- wadi.
Three.
Al-mani
is semen.
And this has its characteristics. How
can we determine that this is semen? How
can we determine that this is mani? How
can we determine that this is madhi? How
can we determine that this is wadi?
We determine it by a couple of things.
Number one
is
on what occasion does it
come out or is the discharge occur?
Al-mani, which is semen
is only discharged at sexual climax.
Not just sexual arousal
but at sexual climax. And it is marked
by the scholars of three things.
Right? The indicator. Number one
it is
something that comes out with
forcefully. Right? It it shoots out. It
comes out forcefully. That's the first
characteristic of al-mani.
Number two
the body reacts to it. The muscles
contract in the body. Okay? So the body
reacts to it.
Number three
after
it is discharged, the body feels
tired and begins to repair. Right?
Usually a person will feel sleepy after
that or drowsy or tired.
Those are three indicators that this is
mani.
This is important because a lot of times
a person will have one of these two
things, especially young young men,
young women will have
these two things become
confused.
They become confused. Al- al- madhi
wal- mani. Why?
Because they both come at sexual
arousal, but the difference is huge.
Because one
causes a person to be in a state of
janabah. They have to bathe.
Right? And the other
demands that a person or requires
that a person make wudu only.
So three things that characterize
al-mani
which is semen, right? Sperm.
Three things that characterize it, that
set it apart from the other two.
Number one
it
comes out at sexual climax.
Number two it comes out forcefully.
Number three
the body reacts to it in the sense that
you know, the muscles contract and so
forth and the body is
you know, has a weakness to it or an
exhausted afterwards. This is mani. Now
paradoxically
paradoxically,
ironically, al-mani is pure.
Al-mani is pure.
It is not considered a type of najasa.
Right?
So al-mani is pure.
It's not a type of najasa, but it
demands that a person bathe.
And al-mani is a type of najasa and
impure
but a person only has to make wudu.
Interesting, right?
The second is al- madhi.
Al-madhi
with a dhal, madhi. Right? And this
usually comes as a prelude to al-mani.
This
comes out or is discharged, appears
before
the
before al-mani, before
climax. It happens when a person becomes
aroused. Right? And
usually it is described by the scholars
as being
transparent.
It doesn't have a color, right? It's
clear.
And it is thick
and clear.
And it comes out when a person is
sexually
activated or has sexual desire.
And its ruling is that a person must
wash it off of their body. What part of
it is on their body
and what part of it is on their clothes,
they have to spray it. And we'll discuss
that in the next chapter, inshallah.
And so that is the second. That is
al-madhi. Al-wadi
comes after urinate ur- urination. Once
a person urinates
if they've got some kind of infection in
their bladder or something that
it will come out. It is usually marked
as
coming out roughly five within five
minutes after urinating, after a person
relieves himself. It is
white in color and it is thick. Right?
This is something all all three
obviously will will compromise a
person's wudu, will break a person's
wudu.
But al-wadi
is impure. It is
a type of filth, a type of najasa. And
the person must wash it off of his
clothes and wash it off of his body.
Al-madhi must be washed off of the body
and
water must be applied to the place of
al- al-
al-madhi.
Right?
sprayed or sprinkled, and not the head.
But al-wadi
demands that it be washed. It has to be
washed. And they break a person's wudu.
So to finish up
[Silence]
What are the three? Who can tell us?
What's the first one?
Al-mani.
Right?
And that is what in English?
Sp- sperm, semen. Okay. The second one?
Al-madhi.
Now that's a that's a mixture
of both, al-madhi.
No, al-madhi.
Right? What is al-madhi?
It is pre- We could call it pre-sperm.
Right? That's what it's referred to in
English. Okay? Well, what's the last
one?
Wadi with a d, right? And that comes
when
Yeah, within five minutes after
urinating. What's important is after
urinating.
I'm going to quiz you on this tomorrow,
[Arabic recitation]